hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show on the program today King Charles
says he's diverting profits from the
crown estate's offshore wind farms to
the taxpayer
the government is on track to miss
two-thirds of its environmental targets
according to a report from its own
watchdog
and low traffic neighborhoods reduce
overall car use according to a new study
into the controversial traffic schemes
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now King Charles has asked for a
surge in profits from six offshore wind
farms on the crown estate worth one
billion pounds to be used for The Wider
public good rather than the royal family
the Royal households Public Funding is
based on 25 percent of crown estate
profits and the King wants to reduce
this so that the treasury keeps more for
public spending with chief executive of
the crown estate Dan labord spoke to Sky
News earlier about that decision
foreign
looking at how we can support our
businesses across obviously where we
have commercial and Retail and
residential Holdings as well as thinking
about the long term you know what
decisions that we need to make today
that can support the country moving
forward both in terms of returning
Revenue to the treasury but also looking
at things like climate change
biodiversity and economic growth
let's get more on this story now our
Royal correspondent Laura bundock is
here with me so Laura tell us more about
why the Kings made this decision well
it's part of its vast and varied
portfolio the crown estate owns most of
the seabed around the UK so that means
if you want to build a wind farm you
need a seabed lease from the crown
estate so this is all about the signing
of agreements of leases for six wind
projects now they're going to be off the
coasts of North Wales of Cumbria and off
Lancashire and also in the North Sea
around Lincolnshire and Yorkshire as
well the idea is they between them will
generate around eight gigawatts of
renewable electricity which is enough to
power 7 million homes it's a long way
off before they're up and running but
the idea is they should be online by
2030. this is actually the fourth round
of this kind of seabed leasing when it
comes to wind offshore wind projects
that the crown estate has been involved
in it is big business for them as well
it's one of the reasons why the estate's
Marine portfolio which includes the
seabed has been increasing so much in
value in recent years now the crown
estate says it's really committed to
backing these kinds of projects these
sorts of solutions to The Climate crisis
things that will help the challenge of
energy security now we have the king
also saying he doesn't want to take any
of the profits from this himself and we
are talking big money here it's one
billion pounds from these six lease
agreements it doesn't all go to the king
it's worth remembering that the crown
estate passes directly to the treasury
they then hand over a percentage to the
Royal household that's what we call the
Sovereign Grant at the moment it's set
at 25 to help pay for Buckingham Palace
Renovations was normally around 15 but I
could say these are Big sums of money
and the king in the middle of a cluster
living crisis does not want to be seen
to be making huge amounts of money I
think particularly when it comes to
supporting a green project like this
given his green credential yeah
fascinating Laura thanks very much
indeed
so let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate stories making the
news and new data has revealed that
temperatures in Greenland are the
warmest they've been in a thousand years
underscoring the growing impact of
human-driven climate change on the
natural world a study published in the
scientific journal Nature found that
temperatures have risen 1.5 degrees
Celsius above the 20th century average
since 1995. Melt from the Greenland ice
sheet is the largest contributor to
Global sea level rises
government progress towards its targets
to Halt and reverse Nature's decline by
the end of the decade has fallen far
short of what's needed according to the
office for Environmental Protection
publishing its annual progress report
the environmental Watchdog concluded the
government's 25-year environment plan
has so far failed to bring about the
changes needed at the pace and scale
required adding that the strategy lacked
Clarity and commitment
the north sea's biggest oil and gas
producer Harbor energy plans to cut jobs
in the wake of a windfall tax imposed on
the sector last year the jobs are set to
be lost in the North Sea Hub of Aberdeen
but the extent of the cuts is yet to be
determined it comes despite the company
forecasting its 2022 cash flow to Triple
to 2.1 billion dollars
new research warns that more than 40
percent of land vertebrates will be
threatened by extreme heat by the end of
the century if High emissions continue
reptiles birds amphibians and mammals
are being exposed to extreme heat events
of increasing frequency duration and
intensity as a result of human-driven
global heating the paper published in
nature says this poses a substantial
threat to the planet's biodiversity
now low traffic neighborhoods have
substantially reduced motor traffic in
residential areas without significantly
increasing traffic on the nearby main
roads that's according to a new study
the traffic schemes work by cutting off
rat runs using bollards or cameras to
stop drivers passing through quieter
streets
supporters of the scheme argue that they
reduce car use they encourage walking
and cycling and they improve air quality
in residential areas but critics say
that they worsen traffic on main roads
slowing Journeys and actually worsening
air quality for those who live there
well I'm joined Now by Hira Khan adiogan
from the climate campaign organization
possible who carried out the research
along with Westminster University so
welcome to you thanks so much for
talking to us how much of a difference
then did you find that these low traffic
neighborhoods make to reducing the
number of cars on those streets
foreign thanks for having me on so uh
this comprehensive study shows that they
made a massive difference so uh on the
inner roads we found a mean average of
uh almost half uh of traffic being
reduced and on the boundary roads we saw
increases of just one percent and so put
that into context on a road that you
know usually experiences about 11
000 cars in in one go uh you know the
Boundary Road saw an increase of maybe
82 cars something like that but the
inner Road saw such substantial traffic
production that we can categorically say
uh that there was a decrease in traffic
that's uh 10 times higher than than what
those boundary roads experienced yes
because people are very split on these
in their neighborhoods aren't they those
who don't like them say that all they do
is drive cars onto those boundary roads
as you say but you're saying the
increase is negligible they might say a
one percent rise and an already busy
road makes it pretty unbearable to a
drive down
so what I would say is those boundary
roads probably are still polluted you
know they're heavily congested and we
need uh tougher measures really low
traffic neighborhoods work for minor
roads and and uh the inner roads that
the low traffic neighborhoods uh were
created to to ease congestion there but
what we need much tougher measures for
for the main roads and we need to reduce
traffic across the board across London
and so we need things like you know a
smart Road user charging scheme for
example and it's fantastic to see that
the Euless is expanding to help people
who live by the a406 all of that is a
part of the picture yes and again those
are other issues that there are some
that feel that they're controversial and
as far as far as your survey is
concerned there are some people who are
questioning the findings saying that
there are 96 schemes but only 46 form
part of the study they've raised the
question of whether the the worst
performing councils perhaps didn't
submit their data what would you say to
that
well I think the report is really clear
we we've used the data that is available
we want to see more monitoring and
evaluation across the board on ltns uh
but I think this this study adds to
loads and loads of research that we've
already produced that low traffic
neighborhoods work and uh you know like
I said they're not a silver bullet we
need loads of other measures as well but
we need to see our politicians get
Bolder and braver to reduce traffic
everywhere so that we can have healthier
happier and Greener cities okay
fascinating stuff and a really
interesting debates we had a hurricane
ADI yoga then thanks very much indeed
for your time
thank you now before we go just a
reminder that the climate Show with Tom
Heap is back this weekend and he's been
speaking to people impacted by The
Vicious wildfires that destroyed homes
six months ago after Britain's hottest
ever day that's on Saturday and Sunday
at 3 30 and 7 30. and we're back on
Monday at the same time see you then